Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Credo nelle persone e credo
nella forza delle loro loro idee.
Per questo, dopo aver trascorso
tutta la mia carriera nelle risorse umane,
ho deciso di cambiare lavoro
e tra tre giorni aiuterò a far volare
le idee degli altri.
Non solo quelle grandi unicamente
delle aziende o delle start-up,
ma anche quelle più piccole.
Quelle che abbiamo tutti noi
e che non lo sappiamo ancora,
ma possono fare una grande differenza.
Oggi vi parlerò di un nemico,
di una maledizione,
che tarpa le ali alle nostre idee.
E di 5 modi per sconfiggerla
e cambiare il mondo, un'idea alla volta.
Viviamo in un mondo di grandi rivoluzioni
e solo negli ultimi anni
queste rivoluzioni hanno cambiato
il modo in cui noi siamo produttivi,
il modo in cui ascoltiamo musica,
il modo in cui ci relazioniamo
gli uni gli altri,
il modo in cui facciamo acquisti
o il modo in cui ci muoviamo, viaggiamo.
Queste sono grandi rivoluzioni
che hanno avuto grandi finanziamenti.
Ma vi posso assicurare che le idee
che cambiano il mondo sono dappertutto
e la maggior parte delle volte
sono piccole.
Noi tutti abbiamo idee.
Ciascuna di queste idee
può fare un piccolo cambiamento,
che però può toccare tante persone.
Magari non milioni come le app
che abbiamo appena visto.
Magari
un po' di meno,
magari anche una persona sola.
Anche se fosse per una persona sola,
varrebbe la pena di provare
a far volare quell'idea.
Pensiamo per esempio
a un gruppo di 10 persone.
Una persona di questo gruppo
trova un modo
di semplificare la vita a tutti gli altri.
Non è necessario
che sia una cosa rivoluzionaria.
Può essere un documento obsoleto
che non va più usato,
un modo diverso di archiviare le cose
e che ti fa trovare i documenti
in modo più rapido.
Ecco, mettiamo che questa innovazione
faccia risparmiare 5 minuti
a ciascun membro del team.
Per dieci membri del team,
sono 50 minuti,
sono 250 minuti alla settimana,
1.000 minuti al mese,
12.000 minuti all'anno.
12.000 minuti sono 25 giorni lavorativi.
Si fanno un sacco di cose
in 25 giorni lavorativi.
E tutto questo da una piccola cosa,
da 5 minuti.
Questo perché, come dice Osho,
la vita non è fatta
di cose incredibili, fantastiche,
è fatta di piccole cose.
Ma quando non chiedi l'impossibile,
quelle piccole cose si trasformano
in realtà eccezionali.
Il fatto è che noi
non conosciamo
il potenziale delle nostre idee,
finché non proviamo a farle volare.
Non ci sediamo e diciamo:
"Adesso trovo un modo
per far risparmiare 5 minuti
ai miei compagni di team,
o trovo il modo di risolvere
la viabilità della mia città,
o costruisco un'app incredibile".
Le idee nascono dal nostro confronto
con la realtà,
dalla nostra voglia di migliorarla
e cambiarla.
È il modo in cui noi rispondiamo
ai problemi che la vita ci pone.
Ora,
Non fraintendetemi, non tutte le idee
sono geniali o hanno avuto successo.
Per esempio, vogliamo parlare di questa
bevanda rumena dal nome un po'
stravagante?
Qualcuno si ricorda
--spero di no--
il gusto dei primi piatti
prodotti dalla Colgate?
O il gusto della Coca-Cola 2 ?
O ha mai preso appunti
sull'Apple Newton?
Ecco,
anche la Apple ha avuto idee
che non hanno volato.
Però l'importante è capire
che se vogliamo avere idee che volano,
dobbiamo avere il coraggio di sbagliare.
Dobbiamo avere il coraggio di esporci
e di esporre la nostra idea al mondo.
Ho lavorato 16 anni nelle risorse umane
e mi ha sempre colpito vedere
quanto le persone
abbiano idee per migliorare
la loro vita lavorativa,
che va da un processo aziendale
alla disposizione dell'area break.
E mi ha colpito vedere quante volte
la tengano per loro stessi
e non la comunicano gli altri.
O peggio quante volte una buona idea
non ha spiccato il volo
perché comunicata male
o presentata male.
E la maggior parte delle volte
la presentiamo male,
per il nemico cui facevo accenno
all'inizio del talk.
Per quella maledizione
che prende tutti noi.
Si chiama la maledizione
della conoscenza.
Spiegata in dettaglio è:
quando sappiamo qualcosa ci risulta
difficile immaginare come ci sentivamo
quando non lo sapevamo.
Quindi, quando noi spieghiamo
qualcosa, diamo per scontato
troppe cose.
Pensateci, ci capita tutti i giorni.
Proviamo a spiegare l'idea
a un amico, un collega
e diamo per scontato un termine inglese,
diamo per scontato un termine tecnico,
diamo per scontato un acronimo.
Per esempio, qualche anno fa,
un direttore finanziario
mi stava facendo vedere i numeri chiave
della società per la quale lavoravamo.
E alla fine della presentazione
ha detto:
"Emanuele, questi naturalmente
sono i numeri BAU".
E a me è venuta voglia di rispondere:
"Miao",
naturalmente.
Per fortuna non l'ho fatto. BAU
è l'acronimo inglese di Business As Usual,
allo stato attuale del business.
Però anche quel direttore finanziario
è stato colpito
dalla maledizione della conoscenza,
dava per scontato
che io sapessi quella cosa.
Ecco, quando si tratta delle nostre idee,
di farle volare,
questa maledizione è ancora più forte,
perché sono nostre,
ce le abbiamo dentro.
Quindi,
sono talmente belle
e ne siamo talmente innamorati
che pensiamo
che verranno corrisposte per forza.
Non è sempre così.
Ecco quindi 5 consigli,
del nostro amico Fonzie,
per combattere
la maledizione della conoscenza
e fare volare le nostre idee.
Primo,
Chi?
Sappiate sempre chi avete davanti,
quando state presentando un'idea.
Non unicamente
dal punto di vista del ruolo
che può avere in azienda,
o dell'età anagrafica,
ma proprio dal punto di vista
della vostra idea.
Rispetto all'argomento
che state per trattare,
avete davanti una platea di esperti,
o no?
Perché,
una cosa è spiegare le nuvole
a dei meteorologi,
basterebbe far ricordare loro
il ciclo dell'acqua.
E sarebbe abbastanza facile.
Ma se lo dovete spiegare a dei bambini?
Questo risulterebbe un po' difficile.
Meglio trovare qualcosa
che sia più vicino a loro,
magari,
il vapore che esce dalla pentola
dove la mamma sta facendo la pasta.
E spiegare che quel vapore è simile
al vapore acqueo che si genera dal mare.
Pensate
alla semplicità con cui Francesca
ci ha spiegato il DNA prima.
Una volta che sapete chi avete davanti,
sapete anche perché
dovrebbe interessargli la vostra idea.
Non è certo spiegandola nei dettagli
che la farete volare in alto,
anzi.
Dovreste spiegare i vantaggi che l'idea
genera e per chi sono quei vantaggi.
Siete sempre voi che dovete adattarvi
alla vostra audience
e non viceversa.
Due.
Semplicità.
In un mondo in cui combattiamo
per l'attenzione,
--e mantenere l'attenzione
dell'audience è difficile--
e combattiamo contro WhatsApp,
i telefonini,
lo schermo di un monitor,
La semplicità e la chiarezza
sono un vantaggio incredibile.
Quanto più un'idea è espressa in modo
semplice, tanto più volerà in alto.
Pensate per esempio al motore di ricerca
che usavamo noi tutti
fino a 12 anni fa circa.
E guardate quello che usiamo adesso.
La semplicità è sempre un vantaggio,
ricordatevi.
Tre.
Emozioni.
Usate le vostre emozioni
e in particolare la passione.
La passione è coinvolgente,
la passione cattura l'attenzione.
Molte volte, e ha fatto anche l'esempio
Alessandro Lucchini nel primo talk,
ci sono persone che
dicono:
"Sono molto contento di essere qui a TED"
o:
"La mia idea è rivoluzionaria".
Ecco, non fatelo! Se non ci credete voi
non ci crederà nessuno.
Ve lo garantisco.
Usate la passione come qualcosa
che fa volare in alto le vostre idee.
Noi usiamo le nostre emozioni nella vita
per fare grandi cose,
usiamole anche per le nostre idee!
Quattro:
Provate.
Anzi,
provate, provate,
provate.
Molti additano Steve Jobs
come un grande venditore di idee.
Lui ne ha fatte volare veramente tante,
veramente in alto.
L'Apple Newton non l'ha progettato lui,
comunque, eh?
Se voi vedete i primi video
di Steve Jobs era bravo,
ma non così bravo
come nelle ultime volte
in cui ci ricordiamo
che presentava i suoi prodotti.
Questo perché, prima del lancio,
lui si chiudeva due o tre giorni
con i suoi collaboratori più stretti
e provava e riprovava l'idea
e continuava a provarla,
finché non era semplice,
finché non era chiara, finché i passaggi
non erano semplicissimi.
In questo modo ha fatto volare
tante delle sue idee.
Cinque.
L'ultimo:
libertà.
Una volta che fate volare la vostra idea,
non è più vostra.
Può prendere traiettorie di volo
che sono insospettabili all'inizio.
Può essere anche presa da qualcun altro
e fatta volare in un altro modo.
Molte delle grandi idee che conosciamo
sono nate in un modo
e sono diventate qualcos'altro.
Il play-doh per esempio, la pasta di sale
che usano tutti i bambini,
è nata come detergente per i muri.
E il pluriball?
Quello che usiamo per impacchettare,
--o almeno così diciamo--
i nostri oggetti preziosi,
e invece stiamo lì a schiacciarlo
come dei matti.
Ecco, è nato come carta da parati.
Quindi non siate gelosi
delle vostre idee, lasciatele libere.
Anche se avranno volato poco
con la sembianza
che volevate darle voi
e sono state prese da qualcun altro
e han fatto un altro volo,
avrete comunque partecipato
a un grande cambiamento.
Quindi, per riassumere.
Uno.
Sappiate sempre chi avete davanti
e perché dovrebbe interessargli
la vostra idea.
Siate i più semplici possibili.
Usate le emozioni
e la passione in particolare.
Provate,
provate,
provate.
E...
liberate le vostre idee.
Vorrei concludere
con un esempio personale.
Questo è mio padre.
È morto due anni fa,
dopo una lunga malattia,
e ha passato gli ultimi giorni
della sua vita in un hospice,
le strutture ospedaliere dove ti accolgono
se non c'è più nulla da fare.
Ecco, sulla porta di camera di mio padre
c'era l'immagine di una barca,
con scritto sopra il suo nome.
Non Signor Mascherpa,
o Giorgio Mascherpa,
solo Giorgio.
Come sulle altre camere dell'hospice.
L'ho sempre trovato uno stupendo gesto
per personalizzare e umanizzare
un ambiente altrimenti pervaso
dalla crudeltà della morte.
E mi sono chiesto: "Chissà chi ha avuto
quella semplice idea?"
Semplicissima.
Un'immagine e un nome.
E
chissà per quante altre persone
è stata di conforto, oltre a me.
Tutte quelle che magari frequentavano
quel luogo per trovare i loro cari,
che stavano per lasciarli.
Ecco,
piccolissima idea.
Pensate a quante idee avete voi, invece.
E non pensate mai
che siano troppo piccole
per avere un effetto
e un impatto sugli altri.
Provate a farle volare.
Usate questi cinque consigli
o trovatene anche altri.
E una volta che ne farete volare una,
vi verrà voglia
di farne volare un'altra,
un'altra ancora e un'altra ancora.
Perché le idee sono
un po' come i cioccolatini,
una tira l'altra.
Usate la passione
e fatene volare il più possibile.
Perché, come dice Leonardo:
"Quando camminerete sulla terra,
dopo aver volato, guarderete il cielo,
perché là siete stati
e là vorrete tornare".
Grazie.
(Applausi)